terrassé par la coved 19 depuis dix mois
la docteure anne bearer peine encore à
marcher elle était pourtant une grande
marcheuse je marchais vite
actuellement
perco et
150 m
aller retour
de marvin
et bonne journée quand je peux
une vingtaine de
jeux fatigué
la docteure bearer a contracté le virus
en décembre dernier alors qu'elle
travaillait au front dans un siège celle
durement touchée par une éclosion de
lakovic 19 10 mois plus tard la fatigue
et des troubles de la respiration
l'affligent toujours mais ce qu'il a
fait le plus souffrir c'est les sciences
le silence sur la coque
et sur tous les gens qui aiment
ca c
encore plus de 7 on se sent la tête du
som s'il vous plaît fillon s'organise
pour que tous les malades partout au
québec puissent avoir accès à 10 mhz
accompagné du collectif cofidis top des
malades et dix scientifiques crie à
l'aide ils demandent à québec de créer
un réseau de prise en charge des
patients atteints de la copie de longue
durée en leur offrant des soins
spécialisés si on laisse échapper ça ça
veut dire qu'on se prépare
véritable épidémie d'invalidité chez des
milliers de gens quand on lui a demandé
ce que québec comptait faire pour ces
milliers de patients françois legault
semble avoir été prise au dépourvu juge
pas au courant le détail c'est du coc
pas comme il faut s'occuper des patients
qui ont l'acavite longue qui ont des
effets à long terme et un os bien et en
sciences en occuper quant à anne
d'erreur la mère de famille reste
optimiste malgré cette épreuve ardue
très dur
je garde espoir et croit fermement que
la science et surtout le temps lui
permettront de retrouver un second
souffle ici jérôme bergeron radio canada
montréal